we had written the puffy chair because
we were in our mid-20s and we were in
relationships and we were all feeling
like is this should we is this did we
get married do we break up what do we do
and everyone was kind of going through
that and then after that movie I mean
you know like Mark was saying we were
desperate to just stay true to ourselves
and what we felt like we had to offer
and we had spent a year on the film
festival circuit with the puffy chair
and we were around all these desperate
filmmakers ourselves included and it was
so desperate and funny as [ __ ] to watch
all these people operating at a party I
mean I'm not kid I mean you you go to a
film festival party and the amount of
agenda going on there like people have a
game plan that's like like you know
tantamount up special ops when they go
to a film festival party and we just
thought it was so funny I mean it was
just so funny but earnest and lovely
like these kids are trying to make their
dreams come true and we also just wanted
to get the [ __ ] scared out of them and
watch them scream but bagging it was not
a plan it was more of an afterthought we
were living in LA after the puffy chair
we've been hired by studio to to write a
movie on spec for them we were writing
that we're starting to make some money
we were getting sent all these movies
this would happen to when you make a
feature that's like pretty good that
goes to a film festival all the studio's
say we love you want to make your next
movie you believe them you really
shouldn't and they say you know then and
they say we want you to direct this
movie and what you get is the really
broken scripts with an actor attached to
it that like that actors going to go in
six weeks unless you can fix that script
and get it on its feet you know anjana
we get all these Christian would be like
this is so great they love the puffy
chair they love what we do they say they
love exactly we want we'll just make
them a pitch that fixes this movie and
and and we'll go make it and we were
going and pitched and they'll be like
yeah we need the lead character to be a
little more aspirational than that you
know and and all and we're like oh
they're not making the same kinds of
movies that we want to make and that
became kind of painfully apparent to us
so you know we would love to sit here
and say like we just wanted to stick to
our guns and be true
was part of it but part of it is it was
so painful for us making that first
feature of ours that was not only not
good it wasn't true to us and it felt so
untruthful that we could never go
through that again and we knew that and
so we were just like well the puffy
chair worked we made it cheaply we sold
it we made a little bit of money let's
just go do that again you know and we we
wrote Baghead strangely enough there
were like some smaller studios who
really wanted to make the movie for like
a million dollars or so and our
paychecks were going to be like eight
thousand dollars to make the movie and
all the movie was going to go my name is
gonna go to the studio and we're like we
can make this thing for like 50 grand
and sell it at Sundance and do a lot
better and after we did that something
really clicked in our minds were like
ooh we might actually be able to make a
living doing it this way